Українці вже не перший рік потерпають від інфляції.
На тлі зростання цін лідерка "Батьківщини"
Юлія Тимошенко стверджує:
Зараз в країні почалася, по суті, гіперінфляція.
Гіперінфляція - це інфляція, що вийшла
з-під контролю, ситуація, коли ціни стрімко
зростають разом із швидким знеціненням грошей.
Формально визначається як інфляція з темпами
понад 50% на місяць. У неформальному значенні
термін застосовується до менших темпів інфляції,
зокрема, щонайменше 100% за три роки, тобто
понад 2% на місяць.
Цього в Україні наразі не простежується. Торік,
за даними Нацбанку України, інфляція склала
13,7%. А у 2016-му - 12,4. Цікаво, що якщо порівняти
ці цифри з двома роками прем’єрства самої
Юлії Тимошенко, то ситуація далеко не краща:
22,3% у 2008 році і 12,3% у 2009-му. Щоправда, тоді
Юлія Тимошенко не називала це гіперінфляцією.
Слід додати, що у 2015 році, в часи прем’єрства
Арсенія Яценюка, Україна справді зазнала значного
спалаху інфляції - понад 43% за рік. Але навіть такий
стрибок не можна назвати гіперінфляцією.
Бо головною причиною є значне вливання грошей
у обіг і відповідно масовий друк нових купюр,
щоб покрити держдефіцит. А в Україні нині таких
тенденцій не спостерігається.
Зазвичай гіперінфляція призводить до повного
краху товарно-фінансової системи в країні і
супроводжується абсолютною недовірою до
національної валюти з боку населення, зокрема
закриття депозитів.
В Україні є інфляція, вона значна, але це
не гіперінфляція. У січні цього року її рівень був
1,5%. Окрім того, нема головних ознак гіперінфляції:
друку грошей для покриття державного дефіциту.